hmm
ladies and gentlemen welcome to all of
you the president of the commission will
now make a statement following the
college adoption of the green deal
this is a press statement the president
will not be taking questions president
the floor is yours
special day
Commissioners agreed on the European
green deal
the European green deal is on one hand
our vision for a climate neutral
continent in 2050 and it's on the other
hand a very dedicated road map to this
goal it's kind of 50 actions for 2050.
our goal is to reconcile the economy
with our planet to reconcile the way we
produce the way we consume with our
planet
and to make it work for our people
therefore the European green deal is on
one hand about cutting emissions
but on the other hand about creating
jobs and boosting and innovation
I'm convinced that the old growth model
that is based on fossil fuels and
pollution is out of date
and it is out of touch with our planet
the European green deal is our new
growth strategy
it's a strategy for growth that gives
more back than it takes away
and we want to really make things
different we want to be the Front
Runners
in climate-friendly Industries
in clean Technologies in green financing
but we also have to be sure that no one
is Left Behind
in other words
this transition
will either be working for all
and be just or it will not work at all
and therefore a crucial part in the
European green deal
is the just transition mechanism we have
the ambition
to mobilize 100 billion euros
precisely targeted
to the most vulnerable regions and
sectors
the European green dealers Broad Road
map
We Care also about biodiversity and
forests
agriculture
and food
green cities
and for example the circular economy
we do not have all the answers yet
today is the start of a journey
but this is Europe's
man on the moon moment
the European green deal
is very ambitious
but it will also be very careful
in assessing the impact and every single
step we're taking
the European green deal is an invitation
for all
to participate
I mean European citizens are changing
their lifestyle to protect the con the
climate and the planet
therefore our European green deal
tells them that Europe is at their site
the European green deal is something I'm
convinced we owe to our children because
we do not own this planet
we just do have a certain for a certain
time the responsibility and now it's
time to act
thank you very much I'm now running to
Parliament I will present there the
European green deal with France
timmermans to Parliament
then tomorrow I will present the
European green deal to our leaders and
the European Council
and from stimmermans will present the
European green deal at cop 25 in Madrid
thank you very much
thank you very much